a guy got uh well how are we going to
say this how are we going to say this
exclusive Senate staffer caught filming
gay sex tape in Senate hearing room Greg
price who's an actual journalist he
tweeted this out can confirm that the
senator Carden staffer who filmed
himself having sex in a senate hearing
room is this guy Aiden Ma separi so here
is now the statement from Aiden Mass
Sosi the guy who this did this thing
this has been a difficult time for me as
I've been attacked for who I love to
pursue a political agenda as I have been
attacked for who I love it's not who you
love should I draw it I don't even know
what I can do at this point like you
can't do that in the
Senate gay